good morning John Green hey there and
happy birthday so I didn't do anything
in the early days of vlog brothers we
did a lot of birthday stuff and then it
got like we kept trying to one-up each
other until it was a lot of work you may
remember this guy he was one of your
birthday presents we made a whole bunch
of these this one's broken in my real
job you were the only one with a bobble
head for a long time until I also now
have one and you can get a set up oh I
don't know who's still got any of these
definitely a different level of quality
and the new ones I think these look
better but you know there's nothing
wrong with this you were wondering what
it looks like without the head as you'd
spring so in order to alleviate the
blinding pressure of having to have an
even better birthday present than the
previous year we just stopped having
birthday presents at all
what do you need got a beautiful family
and a home and a Chevy Volt what else
could a man ask for we're headed up to
our tenth anniversary on YouTube ten
years of doing this and it's very
exciting it's also perplexing like I
don't remember a lot of the stuff that
we've done we have done many stuffs so
many stuffs this week grace Helbig
uploaded a video in which she put stuff
on her head and then tagged me I'm dying
the vlogbrothers either one as if I
haven't already put stuff on my head
brace have you not seen all 1427 of our
videos grace you are nine years behind
us not that I mind I have a bunch of
stuff and I'm kind of an expert at this
I have so many more things that I did
back in 2007 I can do this all day this
is actually the concept Chevy Volt I was
so excited about this car when I was
writing for you could kick that I bought
a diecast version other things I've been
excited about in my life and no longer
am really arrests Assassin's Creed as
fun back in the day it's okay to change
your mind about what you're into but
friends I am still into this scoop it oh
I got getting him out 10 years later it
remains very exciting and weird and
always I'm learning stuff about the
world and about myself made me like
people more it's made me like myself
more and we've been able to do a bunch
of cool stuff being able to launch
things off of this and just try new
things and have ideas so great that this
community has been so supportive of new
things new ideas and as long as they hit
that mix of being like good for the
world
of fun interesting good for the
community
I feel like I'm betraying any of what
we've built here and that's the
important thing
ultimately what do you think Yoshi and I
will say that a lot of the ideas for new
things to do have been Hanke ideas have
been my ideas whereas the best ones have
been your ideas John thinking of two
major ones this in the first place this
was all your idea
and I just followed your lead I didn't
know what we were doing but I was
convinced that you were right that
online video was an amazing glorious
thing even though I wasn't into it the
way that you were and of course our
upcoming Sports Network which remains
unnamed at the moment grace I hope that
this counted as me putting things on my
head this is just a snap as a molecule
from Derek from veritasium snus knatoms
kits they're magnetic they stick
together huh so cool you can build
molecules I may be a bit of a dork and
John happy birthday ready to celebrate
our 10th anniversary which we're gonna
do in the real world in Boston at
nerdcon nerdfighteria and if you can't
do that and you're nearby Minneapolis
maybe you can go to nerdcon stories
instead where John will be but I will
not because then maybe I haven't said
this on this channel yet I've said it a
bunch of different places I've alluded
to it but I'm having a child with
Katherine in October so I on travel
moratorium which is lovely though I do
like I helped out with the content for
nerdcon stories and it does make me
jealous every time I'm in one of those
meetings I'm like this sounds like a
really good conference but hey I do I do
this for me or do I do it for other
people as well other people as well and
also for me alright this one didn't
really have a point did it 10 years it's
common I just did the math people have
spent over 50 lifetimes watching
vlogbrothers video just killing folks
eating up you and lifetimes they left
and right hopefully it's worth it John
I'll see you on Tuesday